The apt get application is your main
interface to a ton of package related
functionality.
We can check out everything you
can do by reading the man page for
it with this command, man apt get.
We see here it can install packages,
it can even remove packages,
it can do all sorts of stuff.
For now, let's see if there
are some packages that are no
longer required that we can
just automatically remove.
We'll do this with the command
apt-get autoremove.
And once again, it's an administrative
task that has to be run as root.
So we use sudo.
After a few seconds,
we're returned back to our prompt to
let us know everything is all done.
Now let's use apt-get to
install new software.
We'll install an application
called finger.
It's something we'll use a little bit
later on when working with users.
We do this by typing the command
apt-get install finger, and
once again using sudo.